in triangle ABC a B is equal to 13 BC is
equal to 14 and AC is equal to 15 let me
just draw that because it seems like a
pretty involved problem so let me see if
how well I can draw triangle ABC so
let's say it looks like that like that
and then like about to draw let me draw
it like that pretty well I could draw a
slightly straighter line there you go so
let's say that this is triangle a B C
they tell us that a B is equal to 13 B C
is equal to 14 and then a C is equal to
15 and then they tell us Point G is the
intersection of the medians and if
you've watched the video on medians and
centroids you might recognize that the
intersection of the medians is just the
centroid so let me show you that so this
is the midpoint of AC so the line
connecting B to that midpoint is a
median let me draw a little bit cleaner
than that shaky hand so that is a median
the line collecting vertex a with the
midpoint of BC so maybe it's gonna go
right about there is also another median
drawing the straight lines is the hard
part
and then finally you have your third
median here connecting C to the midpoint
of a B so it will connect it just like
just like that and we learned if you
watch the video on medians and centroids
that these three means they always
intersect in a point called the centroid
and they even imply that on this vid on
this on this question right here that
it's going to intersect at Point G so
that right there is Point G points a
prime B Prime and C prime are the images
of a B and C respectively after 180 this
must be 180 degree rotation about G what
is the area of the union of the two
regions and closed by the triangles ABC
and a prime B prime C prime so let's
draw the second triangle a prime B prime
C prime so what we want to do is rotate
each of these each of these points about
G
180 degrees so if a is here if we rotate
it if we rotate it 180 degrees about G
it's going to end up so if it's this far
from G right now it's going to be that
far again on this side so a is going to
be a is going to be right over there or
I should say a prime it's the image of a
after being rotated 180 degrees B is
this far right now if you rotate it if
you rotate it 180 degrees the B will
then be about that far the prime will be
that far and same thing for C if it's
this far right now if you've rotated 180
degrees it's going to get it's going to
get about this looks about right it's
going to go about right over there so
you have C Prime
and so if we wanted to draw a triangle a
prime B prime C prime it would look like
this let me see how well I can so let me
draw my best attempt at it so let me so
it would look something something like
something like this and this line should
be proud to that line because it's now
going to be it's the line connecting a
and B it's been rotated 180 degrees this
line should be parallel to this one so I
just want to make drew my best attempt
at drawing it because it seems like it's
going to be relevant and then this line
should be parallel to that one since
it's just rotated 180 degrees so it's
gonna look something it's going to look
something like this
so what they're asking they want the
area of the union of the two regions
enclosed by the triangles so it's
essentially the area of this entire star
is the six pointed star kind of a
slightly skewed or slightly tilted star
of david' over here so this is not you
know this just I'm not doing it in real
time now I made sure I could do this
problem before I did this video but it
took me a while to for it to kind of
jump out at me kind of knowing that most
of these problems don't require to do
some really hard mathematics they a lot
of times you just kind of have to see
something or rearrange things and the
answer jumps out and it's also the case
with this one here and the thing that
jumps out and this was actually my
motivation for making the video I showed
you in the I showed you in the last well
if
last video you watched that if you have
a median of a triangle if you have a
median of a triangle and the centroid of
the triangle is over here this distance
the distance from the vertex to the
centroid is twice the distance from the
centroid to the midpoint of the other
side or another way if you look at this
diagram right over here this distance
this distance is going to be twice this
distance but this distance is also the
same thing as this whole entire distance
right this distance and this distance
are going to be the same it's been
reflected 180 degrees or it's been
rotated 180 degrees I should say and if
this distance is half of that then we
know that this is exactly halfway
between this point and this point or
this is exactly halfway between this
point and this point up there or another
way to think about it we know that this
length right over here is equal to this
length right over here which is equal to
this length over here which is equal to
this length over here and so you start
seeing maybe maybe some triangles will
start jumping out at you and let me see
if I can draw these triangles and have
it
respectably neat so I have this triangle
up here I have this triangle up here we
know it's we could view it as this is
actually going to be a median of this
triangle right over here is going to be
is going to be the same same as the
median I guess we could say or the
equivalent I guess line of this triangle
it's actually going to be an altitude as
well because we're going to see we're
kind of drawing a rhombus and the
diagonals of a rhombus intersect they're
perpendicular to each other so this
actually these are altitudes so this
altitude right here is going to be the
same as this altitude right over here
this this side is the exact same thing
as this side over here for both
triangles so this side is the same thing
as that side this side let me be careful
here we already know we already know
that this side is going to be the same
thing as this side we know that these
two sides are the same because this is
acting as a media
of this triangle over here we already
know that this side this pink side up
here or actually I say this yellow side
I'll direct two marks it's the same
thing as that yellow side down there so
this side is this if this is the same as
this and this is the same in both of
these triangles we know that this side
we know we know that this side must be
must be the same thing as this side
which also must be the same thing by the
same exact argument as this side which
also must be the same thing as this side
right over here or another way to think
about it this triangle is going to have
the exact same area as this triangle
this triangle is going to have the exact
same area as this triangle or you could
view it another way this purple triangle
right over here is going to have this
purple triangle right over here it's
going to have the exact same area is
actually going to be a congruent
triangle to this triangle over here all
of its sides are exactly the same they
actually share one of them well we can
use that exact same argument to say that
this triangle right over here this
triangle right over here is completely
congruent to this triangle right over
there they have all of the same size
even share side in fact we even know
that these two triangles are congruent
to these two triangles up here so these
these are all these are all congruent
now let's think about let's think about
another triangle let's think about this
triangle right over here let me draw
some more triangles over here let me
draw some more triangles over here now
we know we know that this distance this
distance over here that's the distance
that we started about talking about the
medians this distance right over here
from a centroid to a base or from a
centroid to the base that's the exact
same thing as this distance right over
here if you were to draw a parallel line
right over there this obviously it's
just these this line up here and this
line over here are parallel so if you
have if if you are interest is parallel
to this and they're intersecting at the
same points and I won't go into the
depths of proving that they're parallel
it's actually not too hard to do you can
set show that this
distance is the same as this distance
well those two distances are the same
and we share this point right we share
this side right over here we share this
magenta side right over here then we
know we know that this side is going to
be the same thing we know that this side
is going to be the same thing as that
side or we know that this triangle right
over here is going to be the same thing
as that triangle and then we could take
the mirror image we could say well that
uses essentially the same argument
that's going to be the same thing as
this triangle over here and you can I
guess it's a similar argument to show
that that's going to be the same thing
as that triangle over there which is
going to be the same thing as that
triangle over there so and then you do
it on the other side that's gonna be the
same thing there same thing there I
think you see where this is going all of
these triangles are congruent this try
those magenta triangles are congruent to
this triangle right over here which is
congruent to this triangle right over
here which is congruent to this triangle
right over there which is congruent to
that triangle right over there there's
actually multiple ways you can make that
argument I won't go into the depths of
it but the same argument we said to say
these magenta triangles are equivalent
you can make that same argument so this
this distance is exactly half of this
entire distance same argument will tell
you that this triangle is congruent to
that triangle and that triangle is
congruent to that one and that one's
congruent to that one and that one's
congruent to that one so that entire
shape and it was kind of a tedious way
of doing it actually was a little hand
wavy about it I didn't do a very
rigorous proof about it but I think you
can see it's it actually would not be
hard to do a rigorous proof that this
shape this kind of slanted star of
david' is made up of 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 congruent triangles 12
congruent triangles now how many of
these congruent triangles was our
original triangle ABC made up of well we
have 1 we have 2 3 4 5
six seven eight nine so we have twelve
congruent triangles in in the star in
the star we had nine congruent triangles
congruent triangles in a b c so the area
of the star is just going to be twelve
ninth of the area of triangle a b c so
if we can figure out the area of
triangle ABC we know that each of those
triangles are going to be one ninth of
that and then you multiply that by
twelves you'll get the area of the
actual star
so let's actually figure out the area of
triangle ABC so if we do ABC I'll do it
I don't want to lose the problem here so
our triangle looked something like this
now there are formulas for figuring out
the areas of triangles if you just know
the sides
I always forget those formulas but I do
remember the law of cosines and I always
so I always break out the law of cosines
which actually helps you derive those
formulas to figure out the area of an
arbitrary triangle you can figure out
the area of a triangle area of a
triangle is one-half base times height
so if we were able to figure out this
height right over here if we could
figure out this height over here we can
multiply it by 1/2 and 14 or multiply it
by 7 and then we would be able to figure
out the area of this entire triangle so
how can we do that well let's just break
out let's just break out a little bit of
a little bit of trigonometry let's take
let's take this to be theta right over
here the law of cosines tells us that
the opposite side of the angle squared
so 15 squared is equal to the sum of the
other sides 13 squared plus 14 squared
minus minus 2 times the product of these
two sides so times 13 times 14 times the
cosine of theta times the cosine of
theta now what is the cosine of theta
theta is so cosine is adjacent over
potenuse so it's this length right over
here over our hypotenuse so let's just
call this length over here X let's call
this X this obviously this distance over
here would obviously be 14 minus X so
let's just call this X so cosine of
theta is equal to x over 13 so we can
replace this with x over 13 and obvious
if you could solve for X you can then
solve for H using the Pythagorean
theorem but these two characters cancel
out and we are left with we are left
with let's see 15 squared is 225 is
equal to 169 14 squared 14 squared we
have 140 plus 40 plus 16 is 196 so 196
minus minus 2 times 14 X so minus 28 X
let's see if we can solve for X now so
let's add 28 X to both sides let's
subtract let's do a couple of things
let's subtract 225 from both sides so
I'm going to subtract 225 from both
sides and I'm going to add 28 X to both
sides so add 28 X to both sides that
should help us with the sign so on the
left hand side we are left with we are
left with 28 X is equal to now we just
have to do a little bit of math 169 169
plus 196 6 plus 9 is 15 this is going to
be 16 365 did I do that right
15 and then use 68 and 365 and then from
that we want to subtract 225 it's going
to be a 0 this is going to be a 4 it is
going to be 140 so 28 X is going to be
140 or X is going to be equal to you
divide both by 28 let's see 28 goes into
140 let's think about it it goes well it
goes 5 times 5 times 20 is 100 5 times 8
is 40 so it goes 5 times so X in this
situation is equal is equal to 5 so we
can use that information
figure out this height we know from the
Pythagorean theorem that five squared
plus h squared is equal to 13 squared is
equal to the hypotenuse squared is equal
to 169 or we have H squared is equal to
169 minus 25 so it's equal to 144 or H
is equal to H is equal to 12 so now we
can figure out the area of the triangle
the area and sometimes denoted by
brackets the area of triangle ABC is
equal to 1/2 times 14 times times 12
which is the same thing as well this is
the same thing as 7 times 12 which is
equal to 84 now that's just the area of
these 9 that's just the area of these 9
congruent triangles we know that the
area of the whole thing will be 12
ninths of that because this is 9
congruent triangles we want 12 congruent
triangles so the area of the whole shape
so the area of the star the area of the
star I'll put it in quotes is going to
be equal to 12 over 9 times times 84 and
let's see 12 over nine this is the same
thing as if you divide the numerator in
the denominator by 3 this is the same
thing as 4 over 3 times 84 let's see 84
3 does go into 84 how many times it
looks like it goes 28 times let me make
sure so 3 goes into 84 2 times 3 is 2
times 3 is 6 subtract you get a 20 yep
28 times so this is equal to 4 times 4
times 28 which is going to be 80 plus 32
which is equal to 112 let me make sure I
did that right don't want to make a
careless mistake 18 minutes into this
video 4 times 20 is 80 plus 32 is 112
and we are and we are done